Tiffany is with us in Atlanta, Georgia. Hi Tiffany. How are you?
How are you doing better than I deserve? What's up?
And I was calling [because] I want to get your advice [on]
recent financial piece a couple years ago
But we also have a lot [of] burns as far as it so we have about 300 and something
Thousands of student loans do them or Edit well it stops up
300,000 and student loans
Yes
Who's the doctor or lawyer?
Nobody's a doctor [a] [lawyer] is just a lot of expensive food
What are your degrees in honey?
business and
leadership oh
my Lord
What is your household income?
140,000 that's that's good news. Oh my goodness
Overpaid for some degrees, okay ouch
300,000 student loans and what else about
300,000 house talking about 60 between medical and [cars] you think it's like that. What do you owe on the cars?
Like 1501 the body 11 on another okay, all right well
I mean you've got a very very tight budget you got a lot of house, and you got a lot of cars and
You are deeply in student loan debt
so one of two things is going to occur you're going to sell cars and houses and
Move down into just some junky cars and into a little rental property and you're going to use
140 to get rid of the student loan debt or
you're going to keep the house and the cars and
You're going to limp out of this and it's going to take you a lot longer
So when I do the math it takes like Saint-Pierre seasons sort [of] put you know get it close
Now we also do qualify for a loan forgiveness
So why do you qualify meet up after 10 years for non-profit yep after 10 years?
Correct yeah, I don't want to wait 10 years to be out of that
Now I mean you make a hundred and forty okay. You've got three hundred plus
You said another sixty so you 360 thousand?
I mean if we do if we put 60,000 a year on it's done in six years if
We put if we put eighty on it
It's done in four and a half and that means you're in [you] ought to be able to do that. You're just living on nothing
But I mean, but I mean again
[I] if I were in your shoes, I'm going to move way down in house. I'm going to sell my house
And I'm probably going to sell the $15,000 car
Maybe the 11 and just get me a couple junkers and because I'd won out of this mess
And I wouldn't want to wait six years and those cars in that house are going to delay
It's going to add two years at least to this program
maybe three maybe three and you just you guys have bought everything in sight and
[couch] I'm so sorry. I'm sorry you're facing all this but I mean you can do it either way
It's whatever you want to do, but you're right. You're looking at eight
six to eight years
if you stay in the house
And you're probably looking at a really tough three and a half or four if you don't stay [in] the house
What is the what's the trajectory of your career look like income wise are you seeing incomes increase pretty dramatically, or are just slightly?
um [sake] increase as you know the change got like four [different] companies, [so]
[typically] yeah like about another twenty thousand probably would culminate
Promotion or something like that, okay [alright], so that's a pretty decent push, and so you know if we project out three years
Maybe we're not dealing with 140
maybe we're dealing with 180 or 190 at that point on income and see that starts to change the equation to
There, but you guys have you guys have really I mean
You're broke. You're desperately broke
And you're going to start making some dramatic moves in
Cutting lifestyle and some [dramatic] moves in living on the cheap
to clean this mess up and
you know that [that's] what you've got to do there, so
Thanks for the call. [I] wish I wish I had better answers for you, but those numbers are just horrendous. Sorry you're facing that um
one of the things you should get from the show other than entertainment value is you should be learning something and
It should occur to you to think
To yourself how in the crap do people go $300,000 in debt to get a couple of business degrees
What has to be broken in the process they were using in order to let yourself do that?
Okay, well let me tell you a couple things that are broken
Potentially, I don't know what happened exactly there
But I'll tell you what ran in what we're honest in my mind when I hear those kinds of numbers
For something for a situation like that
Number one people think getting a degree from a certain school is going to more likely ensure their success
There is no data
none
anywhere
That indicates that prestige schools create a higher success probability
That's just straight-up bS
It's straight-up bs as a matter of fact more
ceos of fortune 500 companies graduated from public universities than from prestige universities
Wall Street journal [did] a study about two years ago and published it made everybody mad in that world
Now I don't mind you going to a prestige school, but don't go $300,000 in debt to get to business degrees
That's stupid
Okay
And because it doesn't Roi it. Just simply doesn't are
oh
I
forgot sex is a business degree you ought to [think] about this you know and
So I don't mind you going to wharton I don't mind you going to harvard
I don't mind you [going] to yale or vanderbilt
I don't mind you going to those days long as you can write check and go or they're paying for it. It's a free ride
But this idea you're going to go hundreds of thousand dollars in debt because of where you went to school and that's going to Roi
There's no data to support your stupid set of assumptions there none whatsoever. No research at all
You cannot find it on the planet
Now there's some old [boys] sitting around you know sipping on something at the Country club
That'll tell you otherwise but they got nothing to support it. I'll just tell you
the second thing [that] happens there is
If you come from a background if your family is not an educational oriented family
And you're the first of your family to go get an education
Sometimes you believe the lie that says just get an education. It's worth it. Whatever you do
You got to break the family change you got to break the cycle
[you] [got] to do whatever and whatever it takes you go get that education and it'll eat. You know the only shot
You got it got about not being like the rest of us about getting out of the family tree
The only [shots] you got [to] [breaking] the curse on the family as education. It's the only shot education is the answer to everything
Well, it's not
Education is important
knowledge is important, but education is not a magic pill and
It is not worth
Breaking yourself for the next decade
to get two business degrees
Let's say couples aren't feel so sorry for it
What a mess that, they're in and it's one of those two assumptions that probably got them there or both put together
Parents don't want children their stuff like that stop them
Make better choices on where they go to school what you pay for your degree. This is the Dave Ramsey show
Hey guys
Thanks for watching if you enjoyed this video click the subscribe button to get the latest
Content and check out these other great clips from the show